hallo mein name ist luca herr will mega
mega kalt in meinem zimmer becken
gebrochen
herzlich willkommen wir heute zu einem
neuen video auf einem kanal meine damen
kein scherz sie sind ja eine million
besucher alles klein nein freunde wir
sind zurück hier in meinem büro und wir
spielen heute murphy bot ihr seht ihr
schon eingeblendet das ist ja dieses
erkläre euch mal ganz kurz die murphy
board der mel board ist ein skype
account und wir können diesem skype
bekommen beispielsweise schreiben what
if kong crafter voskuhl das blöd weil
ich es nicht bin aber der kann sagen
machen dass ich es werde irgendwann
pickel
swatch ist man schreibt dann halt so was
wie what if barack obama voraus angela
merkel und dann vermischt er das erste
bild wasser bei google von barack obama
findet mit dem ersten bild was er von
angela merkel findet macht daraus eine
person und ich hab euch bei twitter
gefragt ob er irgendwelche vorschläge
habe was ich machen soll ihr habt mir
zahlreiche sachen zugesendet ich glaube
den letzten zwei minuten über 350 tweets
und da hab ich mir ausgesucht dann
schreibt das jetzt im café bar jazz
jungle und katja krawitz das hat mir die
liebe anna carina zugesendet und ich
schreibe jetzt einfach mit dem motto
what is the jungle ist ja auch einen
youtuber finde ich sehr cool sein
konnten trotz katja krasa wie es so und
jetzt warten wir mal ab was der mutter
sagte schick das mich erstmal dass hier
jetzt können wir uns bilder anschauen
guckt euch das an also
sehr schön sergio cabral mit dir mag
euch beide höhe
ich kenn den typ nicht ich glaub ich
denken spanisches model what if sergio
carvajal roßkopf da mal schauen was ich
sage schon die ganze zeit irgendwie klar
abbott in meinem gehirn aber es ist ja
der murphy bordell hack'n'slay geist ist
ein fucking ernstes ich sehe aus wie
eine verdammte missgeburt da irgendwie
das ist das bin ich das sieht man aber
das ist
auch vor der abfahrt so ich nehme mir
hier auf meinem pc auf und hier auf dem
zweiten bildschirm hat ja die ganzen
sachen die tonspur und videofenster dass
ich mich selber sehe und unten rechts
ist gerade so ein fenster von dem
lieferservice fertig gestellt habe und
die brauchen noch 15 minuten bis sie
hier sind
ich hoffe ich habe bis dahin das video
durch miguel pablo und einen kothaufen
ich will überhaupt kein nikotin anfang
das macht er selber schon genug aber wir
haben echt wirklich sehr viele leute
miguel pablo und irgend einen
bescheuerten gegenstand geschrieben
irgendwie andere youtuber mir sogar
gestiegen
pablo und eine klobürste aber ich glaube
das wird sehr verstören aussehen what if
miguel pablo fonds kaufen so murphy bord
sei was kannst du mir daraus zaubern
sobald wir nämlich diese großen
nachricht von ihm bekommen heißt es
eigentlich dass er es hinkriegt dass
aber kein kothaufen das sieht aus wie
ein ganz normaler mensch bist du mal
eingegeben wortes mit pablo muss fit und
darauf antwortet der märkte pumpen punkt
wahrscheinlich ist einfach die wahrheit
julian beim und ein baum mal schauen ob
da etwas zu sagen kann ich weiß nicht ob
es mit solchen sachen funktioniert okay
ich bin raus was soll das darstellen das
ist ein baum mit einem bild von joe drin
und unter dem mund ist irgendwie noch im
mund
ich wette ich habe davon heute nacht
albträume du dich mit kelly kelly ist
ein youtuber aus london kommt aber
glaube ich aus südafrika sowie ich das
richtig einschätzen kann deswegen viele
sagen mir ich sehe halt ähnlich ich weiß
nicht wieso aber ich glaube man kann das
selber immer nicht so gut selber
einschätzen also jfks berlin warcraft da
geben wir einmal schauen was die murphy
bot dazu sagt ich denke dass mich jetzt
so gar nicht mehr so eine übelste
missgeburt sein es könnte tatsächlich
ein mensch sein so einen smiley sticker
und tomaten oder apfelsaft what if
smiley wars tomatensaft ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob es funktioniert es
müsste ja eigentlich als meine und
tomatensaft alleinstehenden
wörter ok es klappt nicht er schreibt
gerade based learning and description
estate heftige back to you later und des
wollen das heißt einfach dass es nicht
hinkriegt war dass nicht personen sind
oder so irgendwie sowas aber wir machen
direkt weiter mit der nächsten sache wie
japan und die hadid what if dieser
panofsky hadid dieser plan ist ein die
youtuber aus deutschland und die hadid
ist ein ultra krass geiles model und die
mischung der beiden sieht so aus ist
nicht mehr so schön das ist ihr hobby
meine damen und herren ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen weil es getan hat las doch
einfach mal ein like da wär super cool
wenn wir irgendwie so 40 millionen
hinkriegen würden wir auf jeden fall
krass wenn ihr jetzt noch dran seid dann
schreibt man in die kommentare smiley
dann sehe ich immer wer von euch rufen
ist bis zum ende ko ich weiß nicht wie
ich das hier in meinem zimmer jetzt
machen soll aber er findet hier irgendwo
ein smiley eingeblendet da könnt ihr
drauf klickt main kanal abonnieren und
sich hier hier hier hier hier findet ihr
ein video eingeblendet wo ich irgendwas
anderes gemacht habe also wer auf jeden
fall chillig wenn ihr da auf jeden fall
auch mal vorbeischaut
weil er macht ich klicks und durch
klicks werde ich mich natürlich auch
mein geld was eigentlich in meinem essen